today we're going to be speaking with
seth moskowitz who's a journalist
writing about american politics and
technology and an editor at persuasion
magazine he's also author of the article
the reactionary trap which i've talked
about before with my audience seth
really great having you on today thank
you very much for having me i'm excited
to be here so i mean just just to start
with let's talk about
um i have made the case to my audience
that much of what is currently
associated with the american right wing
is not really conservative by any
definition of the term but is really a
sort of neo-reactionary movement can you
talk a little bit about when we say
reactionary what what are the
characteristics of a reactionary
political movement
yeah well fundamentally what a
reactionary is somebody who wants to go
back to the way things were before
politically or socially essentially they
want to roll back the clocks so where a
progressive might want to see some form
of change to push things into the future
conservative might be a little bit more
focused on tradition and skeptical of
change but maybe more open to it a
reactionary somebody who wants to roll
back the clocks to the way things were
before and so in my article i lay out
two
things that i think kind of are
hallmarks of a reactionary the first is
that they lose sight of any sense of
proportionality um something that they
see as a threat
they are unable to kind of judge if it's
a five alarm fire or if it's something
that's kind of a minor threat that they
should be minorly concerned about
and the second is that their politics
becomes one of opposition
they lose sight of their their
principles and their values and the
things that they want to see in the
world and they become focused only on
opposing things that they dislike
now in hearing that it really sounds
like trumpism right i mean like when i
hear you say that i think okay so
a movement of opposition here's
something joe biden wants to do nope
we're not gonna we don't want him to do
that here's something uh barack obama
did now here's why we're gonna undo it
without really bringing policy proposals
to the table and also the fear piece
which is
critical race theory is going to be a
disaster with no proportionality in
terms of is it actually something that's
being taught
trans bathroom issues or trans women in
sports with no sense of the scope of
these issues am i right in in applying
it in this way
yeah i think so and i think the
important thing that i've noticed is
that really what it feels like to me is
our dividing line in politics seems to
be this culture war and i think what
happens with reactionaries as they kind
of glom on to
the the politics of the day and the
things that's making people most furious
and most angry and today that's the
culture war and social issues so when i
think about who is a reactionary in
contemporary politics i don't think
about what their positions are on tax
policy or health care as much because
really like it seems like today in
politics you can kind of have opinions
on
those issues and be on the left or right
what really matters and what really
feels like the dividing line in politics
today
is cultural issues and social issues so
the reactionaries that i see are focused
like you said on um critical race theory
in school on
the current
fear about gender being taught in
elementary schools
black lives matter all these cultural
social issues that seem to have taken
over our politics today i think those
are where reactionaries are glomming
onto when are really tacking and saying
we see these changes that are happening
and we want to go back to the world
before those changes were happening
now in the article the reactionary trap
which we will link to
you also point out the left is not
immune from this
and also that social media
has a role to play
in kind of creating these
fear-based reactionary almost like
feedback loops so can you talk about
that a little bit
yeah so in article i talk about a few
people who were
on the left and kind of jumped the shark
and became reactionaries like i was
speaking about on these cultural and
social issues and the point that i
wanted to make is that i think that
people on the left need to be aware that
it's possible for them to become
reactionary even if they think look i'm
left on health care i'm left on gun
issues i'm on the left so i can't be a
reactionary they need to be aware that
because the dividing line in politics
today seems to be these social issues if
you become a reactionary on
somehow every single one of these social
issues um it's possible that maybe
you're no longer a member of the left
but you become sort of a reactionary and
that you need to be aware of of this so
that maybe you can kind of
avoid
a politics that only relies on
opposition and and is only based on fear
and you need to start to have a positive
vision for maybe what you want your
politics to look like and you want the
country to look like um and so
essentially the article talked about a
few people these people who were on the
left and sort of sublimated they skipped
the middle phase and became
reactionaries on the right and it would
and they i think a big part of what
happened to them is that they got
involved on twitter they started to get
a feedback loop of people who were
rewarding them for criticizing the left
on social issues they built up an
audience of those type of people and
then they were unable to criticize the
left on any issues and they sort of
became reactionaries
out without any any real thought about
what was happening to them just by
following their instincts and following
their social media following
yeah i can kind of understand how it can
happen because you know over the last
many years i've waded into topics like
for example when the term regressive
left was a big thing
i was glad to say hey you know what
there is this thing of people who
operate under the label of being left
but they're really quite authoritarian
and that's not a leftism that i
recognize right for example which to me
is relatively uncontroversial like these
things exist in any political movement
and there was a reaction a very loud
reaction from a slice of my audience
focused exclusively on that which if i
had just latched on to that
it probably would have pulled me into a
completely different audience maybe it
would have been lucrative maybe it would
have would have allowed growth i was
only interested in going as far as i
believe the facts suggested on that but
it seems like you can you will very
quickly start hearing from a slice of
your audience and they will pull you
towards those views
i think that's 100 right and it's
oftentimes going to be the loudest and
most active part of your audience and so
you're going to see all these people
reacting to the thing that you said that
was maybe the most exciting and you're
going to say oh wow maybe this is like
what's getting my audience excited i
should give them more of this content
it's called audience capture and i think
it's something that the blue checks on
twitter
and a lot of these people
who are maybe more reactionary on their
social views get a lot of a response
from those people on twitter and they
get really pulled into that world and i
don't think it's i don't think it's only
something that happens on the right i
think it can happen on the left too
and i think it just happens to be that
it's the most radical size of either
base that really really is the most
active on twitter and on social media
and it's really pulling people to the
most
to the most
radical parts of their party or to their
social movement um and i think it's
honestly particularly noticeable on the
right on twitter um only because
it's it it seems like it brings out the
most vile part of people and it really
gets them excited so you see it on
twitter um when you're just when you're
scrolling through and it gives you an
emotional reaction
and you end
and
pulls out the side of you
that wants to respond and wants to get
engaged and i think it's important to
take a step back and say well this isn't
how the world actually is this is just a
certain portion of twitter that's really
this reactionary in this
grotesque yeah and i've i i find that i
will often get questions like as an
example there were i don't know if you
remember this but shortly after trump
was elected in 2016 we saw the rise of
the women's march and then there was
this controversy where some of the
women's march leaders felt that jewish
women were sort of like not
intersectional enough or not
discriminated against enough to qualify
for like board or leadership membership
i called that out wholeheartedly and
talked about you know the dismissal of
anti-semitism and and jewish discrim
anti-jewish discrimination but i also
recognize like this is a pretty small
slice of the left it was sort of like an
attempt to keep that proportionality in
check as you mentioned
yeah i think that's really important i
think there was a study that does done
um the hidden tribe study and it said
like seven percent of of users on
twitter are the most
are progressive activists about seven
percent are conservative reactionaries
or something equivalent on the right but
that they create the vast majority of
the content on twitter um and i think
that's because
one they're probably the most excited
about their political projects the most
active and two i think that they make it
so that the rest of the users on twitter
are fearful of of saying anything or are
fearful of using the platform because
they might get attacked by
one or either side of those of the of
the political spectrum right and so i
think yeah
no well i was i was going to say
what are the if we have an interest in
having some tools with which we can sort
of like pump the brakes when we start
getting sucked into some of these things
you you sort of alluded to some of these
things which is one is asking how big of
a problem is this really what are some
of the other questions that one can kind
of ask themselves as they start getting
pulled into some of these reactionary
loops
yeah i think the first and foremost
thing is to make sure that you have
principles and values that you're
following
rather than just reacting and seeing
something and saying oh that scares me
or i don't like that i'm gonna go on the
other side of that issue i think it's
really important for people to think
through
what are my values what is my political
project and what is the positive vision
that i have for the world
the second is being willing to consider
the possibility that you're wrong
i think it's really important for people
to understand that
they're not always right and one of the
amazing things about twitter is that we
can outsource asking questions we can
outsource we only have one brain and
when there's millions of brains on
twitter
on twitter i think it's useful to think
okay maybe i'm wrong i need to really
consider what other people are pushing
back on me for or or the the ideas that
they're bringing to the table
and then the last one i think is to
avoid us versus them thinking
it's really easy to fall into the trap
where you say this is my side i'm going
to agree with everything on this side
and everyone who is on the other side of
this political issue or on the other
side of the political
divide
has bad motives or is wrong on every
single issue and so i think if you do
those three things one make sure you
have a positive vision um two
don't
don't um fall into us versus them
thinking and then three
um be able to consider the possibility
that you're wrong then you'll avoid this
this reactionary thinking that a lot of
people have fallen into what do you
suspect happened with someone like for
example dave rubin who you write about
in the article you know i i used to be
quite friendly with dave and we would
text and chat on the phone sometimes
years and years ago
and more recently you know he's attacked
me publicly he's kind of sent me texts
privately and like my view has been
i don't know if he was like 38 or 40 at
the time that this political reawakening
kind of happened but i've not really met
people in my life whose politics so
dramatically changes at that age unless
they were almost like not even engaged
at all and they didn't even really have
like a formative politics so it's hard
for me to imagine that his views really
changed so it's easy to say
he was captured by the audience and he
was captured by you know getting to know
trump and this type of thing but i i
just don't really know what to make of
it like what's your sense of that
particular example
yeah it's hard to get into into people's
heads but generally what i think i think
happens to a lot of these people
um
is that they go against well one i think
it's important to notice that the the
mid-2010s the early 2010s and when trump
came along there was a lot of social
change in terms of black lives matter
and there was a lot of this cultural
change that made people
fearful so i think that brought out a
certain type of person who maybe was
progressive on other issues but then
they realized that they maybe they're
more reactionary on these more cultural
issues
the second thing i think that happens a
lot is that maybe someone who's on the
left goes against
one of the progressive
dogmas or one of the progressive
catechisms on these progressive issues
and then they get really dog piled by
people on the left and they think whoa
whoa
what is happening i thought these were
my allies i thought these were my
friends and then they kind of rather
than think having a somewhat rational
reaction and thinking
okay either one maybe i got this issue
wrong or two maybe the rest of my team
is being a little bit irrational on this
this issue they kind of jump to the
other team and then the other team or
the other side accepts them because
they say look now we have someone from
the left on our side right things think
that it gives them more credibility and
in a sense it does i mean these folks
are very useful to the right it seems to
me
yeah i think it is too because when
people when people on the right say look
we even have people on the left who are
joining us on this issue this issue this
issue and they once were really like the
young turks are a far progressive
left um then they can say oh the left
has kind of just gone crazy on these
issues um and maybe maybe there is some
time for reflection on both sides like
the left could say really think through
do we need to be dog piling people who
go against us on one specific issue is
it really worth like ostracizing
somebody and kicking them out of our
club just because they go against one of
these
one of our progressive dogmas
and and the the the people who are
leaving the left need to really
reconsider like are these the people
that i really truly align with on all my
political beliefs um or am i making just
kind of a
rash reaction to being attacked online
yeah i think both sides are important
the people doing the leaving should
really consider whether they're aligning
with with the right people but the
people putting in place the litmus or
purity test should also kind of kind of
consider the impact of that we've been
speaking with seth moskowitz who's a
journalist writing about american
politics and technology he's an editor
at persuasion magazine and we'll link to
his article the reactionary trap seth i
really appreciate your time today thank
you very much i appreciate being here